escribe 18% como decimal y como fracción
simplificada lo queremos aquí es primero
es reescribir este 18%
y saber que ese por ciento significa por
cien
viene de cada 100 por cada 100 por
ciento lo que equivale a 18
de cada 100 o como lo conocemos en otras
formas 18 centésimas cuando tenemos un
número sobre 100 tenemos ese número
representado por centésimos 18 sobre 100
18 centésimas esos 18 centésimas
también lo sabemos representar como 0.18
y de hecho con esto tenemos nuestra
primera respuesta vamos a poner como
decimal que 18% se representa como 0.18
centésimos ahora esto será nuestra
respuesta como decimal qué pasa con la
fracción simplificada yo ya tengo aquí
una fracción sin embargo esa fracción
todavía no está en su forma simplificada
vamos a ponerlo aquí tenemos 18
centésimos o como fracción podemos decir
18 sobre 100 para que nosotros podamos
llegar a la fracción simplificada lo que
vamos a hacer es buscar factores comunes
ambos números tanto el numerador como el
denominador terminan el número par lo
que nos implica que son divisibles entre
2 así es que vamos a dividir entre 2 18
entre 2 y el denominador también 100
entre 2
y de esta manera tenemos 18 / 29
100 entre 250
en este caso el 9 es un número primo
solo se puede dividir entre 1 y entre 9
y el 50 realmente no se puede dividir
entre 9 ya no tienen factores comunes
entre ellos más que el 1 así es que esta
será nuestra respuesta como fracción
simplificada
y bien estuvo muy muy fácil recorrimos
todo un camino tal vez mucha historia
pero la intención es que vean lo
sencillo que es ahora si ustedes en un
futuro tienen por ejemplo un número
con un porciento lo que ustedes pueden
pensar es que ese número
está sobre 100 por lo que comentábamos
aquí por ciento por cada 100 en este
caso específico tuvimos 18 por ciento y
se representó como 18 sobre 100 ó 18
centésimos y una vez que ustedes saben
que este 18 centésimas que estos son 18
centésimas bueno lo pudimos lo pudimos
representar así otra manera en la que se
puede pensar es la siguiente teníamos un
número frente al por ciento en este caso
ese 18
tiene un punto decimal aquí y le puedo
agregar los ceros
como decimales para tener mayor
precisión lo que nosotros haríamos en
este caso también es conocer que este
punto decimal al tenerlo por ciento si
lo queremos representar como decimales
recorreremos el punto decimal un par de
veces al y aix a la izquierda es decir
estamos dividiendo entre 10 y entre 10 y
de esa manera nos queda punto 18 que en
este caso tendríamos cero enteros y se
dan cuenta es exactamente nuestra
representación de los decimales
una vez que ya tengan sus números sobre
100 pueden sacar la fracción
simplificada recuerden que para ello hay
que buscar el factor común y dividir
tanto el denominador como el numerador
espero haber sido clara y que lejos de
confundirlos les aclare como bastantes
dudas nos vemos en otro vídeo